MARK MIRCHANDANI: Get ready.
Here it comes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
[GASPS] That was close.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Whew!
It's a good thing
we had this defense.
But what happens when
someone attacks my cloud
infrastructure?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, no problem.
That's why we've
got Cloud Armor.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Wait.
Armor made of clouds?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: No, Cloud
Armor for Google Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
With Google Cloud Armor,
you can protect your network
and infrastructure
against denial
of service attacks, monitor
security, and much more.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh.
Well, that sounds
like a must have.
How do we get started?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
let's jump right in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's start with what is Cloud
Armor, and how does it help.
Cloud Armor it's
a network security
offering for protecting
your Google Cloud
deployments against
Layer 3 through Layer 7
DDoS attacks by leveraging
Google's global edge
infrastructure and
DDoS defense expertise.
Cloud Armor works with global
HTTP/HTTPS load balancer,
which provides built-in
infrastructure DDoS defense.
You can create rules using
combination of Layer 3
to 7 parameters and geolocation
to protect your deployment.
You can also use
predefined rules
to defend against cross-site
scripting and SQL injection
defenses.
Create the policy and apply
to more than one service.
In Stackdriver
Logging, you can see
if the policy was
matched and applied
to the incoming request.
You don't always have to apply
the policy and rules in Access
or Deny mode.
You can understand
the access patterns
by using Preview
mode to ensure you
are blocking correct traffic.
You can also enforce
access control
based on IPv4 and IPv6
addresses or CIDR blocks.
All right, enough talk.
Now let's see how to
set up Cloud Armor.
On Google Cloud console,
choose Network Security
under Networking, and
then Create Policy.
Give your policy a name.
Select the rule action
from Allow and Deny.
Then Add Rule.
Give your rule a description.
Under Conditions, choose a type.
Right now, under
the beta release,
you can select IP
address ranges.
Provide the matching criteria
with IP address range
and select the
action Allow or Deny.
Initially, you may
want to just preview
the traffic under this rule.
So select Enable
checkbox to just review.
Priority determines the order
in which the rules are checked.
So accordingly, we're just
going to set 1,000 in this case.
Now, the last step
is to set up targets.
Targets are GCP resources that
you want to control access to.
You will need to have a
predefined, load-balanced
target.
So select that as one of
the targets that you want.
You will see the policy
create on the dashboard.
In order to test if the policy
worked, access the backend.
In Google Cloud console,
navigate to Stackdriver Logging
and expand the recent log.
And you will see the
enforced security policy
under JSON Payload.
There you have it.
You just created a simple
backless policy in Cloud Armor
and verified that it worked
in Stackdriver Logging.
So Mark, that's how easy it
is to set up Cloud Armor.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Wow,
with all that security,
everyone should be using it
to keep their network safe.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: That's right.
And you can get
started right now
using Google Cloud Armor to
protect yourself from attacks.
Woo.
Don't forget to like,
subscribe, and comment below.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And if you
want to get in contact with us,
click the link below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]